[Music]
and this is why news this is what I'm
hot sorry sorry it's a minute I called
hot dog yeah I know actually have you
read them not on the fridge and went
when I was a kid I would eat them at oh
yeah that's true I did that as a kid
anyway get back on track as we were poor
yeah what are we doing what are we doing
a writer discusses the real reason women
are often control freaks I want to know
why are we control freaks daddy issues
DNA makes sense done what's the
definition of a control for it's when
you say to your man let me do it just
let me do it oh let me do it now I'm not
that person
yeah it's like oh just let me do it I
fight against that I fight against that
cuz then if you just do it too much then
they'll never want to do anything and I
don't want to get to that point I kind
of [ __ ] around so that you'll do that
cuz they know they're set up to like get
out of stuff but then if you make them
learn how to do it the right way
yeah well no for me I just know that
he's good at I'm fortunate enough to be
in a relationship where it's 50/50 and
like there's areas where I know I'm good
at and then there's errors I know where
I suck and he's good at so then we just
kind of like trade off
yeah I'm not let me do it let me do it
yeah I'm 100% oh yeah we know Tiff's in
this relationship I'm so the let me do
it girl and I have actually been
struggling struggling a lot myself to
overcome that like perfectionist side of
me and I didn't realize like why I was
doing it so much but then once I dug
deep and then I realized well okay it's
a control thing growing up I didn't feel
like I had control of a lot of
situations I was in and so that's kind
of how I cope with with my lack of
control in my life is by controlling
little insignificant things and but so
that's one part but then reading this I
was like oh that's the other part too so
what they're saying in this article here
is that women we tend to be the more
like control obsessive person in the
relationship because what they're
talking about here is that a lot of the
times the men they kind of rely on that
yeah
like okay well you you want to do your
way you can do it better I
I can't do it and they don't even try so
then because you as a woman I've already
felt like you know what I try to give
them this task before and they just it I
just I don't want to be let down again
so it's just like let me just do this
yeah obviously like you're not putting
in the work and you don't care enough to
do it the correct way or whatever it is
and it's just being done like half-assed
so they're just one example that they
use here that the writers great-uncle
pointed out that years prior he had
decided to put in the emotional labor of
booking flights for himself and him and
their great-aunt only to be met with
anger because he had done it wrong and
box yeah and so I that's what they're
saying that it's the this writer here is
this argument a lot that it's not that
men can't or won't do the work is that
they are just schooled it every time
that they try always [ __ ] do it wrong
just do it right it's true but can I say
that like there needs to be moms
teaching their sons how to do yes I've
seen it too many guys that don't know
how to do laundry yeah don't know how to
wash your dish properly you're right I
didn't like even I wasn't even doing
that many chores as a kid but like
everyone learns that like and Steve even
like felt bad that he didn't know how to
do those things and he like was mad that
his mom never taught him and I was like
man mom's we got a teacher so I know why
that is because mom's baby their sons
they rely and co-parent with their
daughters that's so true heaven I don't
know the reduction all things I don't
have a daughter but I totally know and
realize that I am doing that Isaac we're
now he's 11 and he's still like I've
tried to ease into teaching him how to
wash his own clothes and help out with
the dishes and he his responsibility is
like cleaning up the kitty litters
but even that he'll just half-ass it and
I'm trying to like tell him like no this
is the correct way to do it but then I
get scared because I know that I have
that in me where I'm like [ __ ] it might
take it a little too far where I'm being
a little too perfectionist and I don't
let him learn so I'm like and this
really weird
don't you let him do it his way but
you're like this
a this is Z I want you to get to Z do it
your way and then we'll talk about how
you did it yeah so it's not really the
process if she's still not getting to Z
like I don't have even being done so
like for example the kitty litter
example is like you're supposed to scoop
up all the poop because we have a
particularly door where you don't have
to it's not the one that crumbles so the
poop is there and then there's like ppad
than that that gets cleaned out just he
doesn't worry about that it's just the
poop that he has to pick up and then the
pellets so the pellets get thrown
everywhere cuz the cat scratched so his
only responsibility is like okay scoop
out the poop and put like pick up the
pellets and put them back and he you
won't like shield they'll still be like
poop nuggets there and then like the
pellets will still be there and I'm like
okay so this is how you do it in like
I'm trying to did you ask him like what
how did you miss this yeah I'll ask him
here just be like yeah we talked that
that's when I would be like no no a guy
about it guys just like half a thing
right but see like you're already
training him to be that guy yeah so when
his girlfriend and his wife or whatever
comes from the pictures at the scene and
then when he's washing a dish and he's
like and then she's like always let me
do it you know and then he's gonna go
yeah you know yeah that's what Steve did
yeah that's yeah I got lucky cuz you
guys no Bart's mom supports moms like a
very eccentric woman so she she was a
single mom pretty much cuz just him and
his her I don't the [ __ ] for X minutes
that Bart's dad and mom just who had a
really volatile relationships and he
wasn't really in the picture that was in
him fixture so Bart would say that his
mom like every weekend like he would
wash he would wash the car all by
himself starting at like five or six
like years old so I think that's what
you were saying I would agree yeah but
because his mom like really trained him
to do all that and like clean the floors
and plus he was in the military like the
military trains you all all that [ __ ]
too because both of skis brothers went
through the military and they all know
how to fold [ __ ] they know how to do
dishes they know how to do all that [ __ ]
Steve doesn't it like he does the
half-assed thing like he'll sweep the
floor there's still cat hair everywhere
I see the pills going back to the Isaac
thing right so yeah he doesn't do it but
I tell him like no I'd do it again you
didn't
yeah but then I also have like childhood
experience with like my stepdad was such
a perfectionist like he made me clean
the bathroom four times one in one day
because it wasn't good enough so I'm
like [ __ ] like I'm so scared of going to
the extreme yeah I am like literally
like [ __ ] like where do I go but it's
not that you're aware of it you know
that you're not gonna go to the extreme
yeah you know because you know you're
like alright to attempt is enough like
move
you know like tomorrow you'll do it
better but I think there's also like a
reward and Punishment system where it's
like well you didn't do it right so you
don't get to play with whatever you put
and play with or you don't get to
outside because it's kind of crazy to
think about the way my mom raised me
yeah oldest daughter and like her
youngest son who's like 16 now my
brother like I started paying fifty
bucks a month to live there when I was
like 17 oh yeah
and like as soon as I got a job and now
he's like about to be 17 and like my dad
sent some money and she said you know he
needs ISM I'm like a woman like are you
like I'm that same energy I keep the
same energy and she tells me well she's
my last one and I'm like me yeah my
parents my parents were like well you
could handle that but your brother can't
handle that he can only focus on one
thing at a time so handicapping have a
job or anything like yeah and exactly
cuz you well of course he can't handle
he's never been forced to like I didn't
feel like I could handle it until like I
needed to yeah yeah and like continuing
with the writers saying here so then
with that uncle example so they're
saying like she was saying that the
reason why the great aunt got so upset
because he didn't do it right they had a
six-hour layover in Acapulco that's deal
it's just it took away the first
vacation day mm-hmm and it's just the
fact that he didn't examine the entire
flight itinerary before booking so it's
like mm-hmm
it's that whole like well he's trying
but not like really happy they don't get
the lit like the little thing the
detail-oriented things because like
sometimes people like clean and he
licked legit I don't think he sees the
mess like I don't think he sees it and
then I have to point it out and I'm like
that cuz I used to be that way but then
I really like wanted when I started like
having my own things like wanted them to
be nice and um and like I'd be like you
didn't see this comp of the cat hair
like right here like in the middle of
the floor and he's like I guess I just
didn't see it and like so he's getting
better at seeing things but it's still a
work in progress and it's harder to
because he's not my kid so like I don't
want to patronize him yeah and I don't
want to make him feel bad and he is like
trying really hard and like he's gotten
better at making the bag he's gotten
better he'll be like how do I do your
clothes cuz I always said he did my
clothes wrong he shrunk a lot of my
clothes and I'll get so pissed and he's
like show me how to do it but every time
I tell him and then he does it wrong and
and so he needs I don't know if he needs
to write it down or something or like I
don't know if it's just like a training
like he needs to continually do it and
make it a habit but like yeah there's a
lot of guys like that yeah and it's
crazy because we end up being like moms
to the husband yes and that's why we
stop having sex with them yeah and I
think it's very common where the women
because like I have family members who
are like I don't want to be your mom
like I already have a kid with you you
are just like another part of the the
bundle of kids like I like and then the
men get like oh she's so mean to me she
doesn't love me she doesn't want me you
know and it's like well [ __ ] if you did
it right the first time they point that
out in this article here it's called
maternal gatekeeping and so it that's
where there's a problem of emotional
labor imbalance and that's where that
stems from because they're saying that
there's already an imbalance partnership
so then now you just become their mom
because they're like let me just do this
[ __ ] then if you're not even gonna try
to put the work in to the emotional
labor right this writer here is saying
like that they don't believe that women
need to completely let go in order to
achieve balance it's developing a set of
shared standards
yes partners are going to show up for
their shared life need and to be based
on what is going to best benefit benefit
both parties and the rest of the family
that's applicable and so you it just
really requires an open conversation
that goes beyond if you want it done
your way do it yourself yeah so yeah and
so most men need to step up yeah I mean
me and Joe actually have this
conversation like three days ago because
I was not feeling well and I had like a
ton of [ __ ] - dude like prep for jacking
these or whatever and I was just like oh
my god and then we had like people were
supposed to come over or something so
he's like okay I'll help clean up and
I'm like alright cuz I know it's gonna
suck great so then he's doing like
laundry and stuff and he's doing it all
half-assed and like it's he all the
socks are you know balled up the
long-sleeve shirts or else like stuck
together and and I'm sorry I had to sit
down I was like okay don't get mad and I
sat down and I talked to him and I was
like okay I see what you're doing is
you're putting effort into our
relationship by trying to help me now if
you want to do it in a way that I'm
gonna appreciate can I teach you how I
want it to be done yeah because I want
to appreciate the fact that you're going
out of your way to do something that you
don't normally get a daily basis and
he's like okay yeah so then I literally
taught him like from baby steps baby
steps I'm like you have to open up the
clothes like all this stuff and that's
like HS yeah so we spent like two hours
and I taught him how to clean everything
like he didn't know how to use the
Swiffer he was just like what is this
yeah like so everything and I think it
was a really healthy weight cuz normally
it is I would keep doing that oh you
[ __ ] it up I got a read yeah now the
dishwashers all loaded up wrong like I
got to rewash the dishes yeah he just
hears like you did a bad job you get a
job ate no enough no helpful things to
finish it yeah because yeah that's what
they're saying
- it's like as women we need to put in
the effort to teach and then mend me to
put the effort in to try yeah yeah yeah
I like to think of myself as very
patient like even with my boyfriend walk
you ask me like what do you want me to
do and I'm like no no you do what you
want to do and then I'll like I'll I'll
deal with the consequences of that and I
don't even put it in that way but I mean
like if it doesn't come out how I wanted
to it's how you wanted it to and it's
okay for both of us you know because
it's your way and we don't live together
so you know like of course we're not at
that point yet but even like planning a
trip or planning a date or like planning
a dinner you know like a few goes if we
go somewhere that I don't like to eat or
like something like that I'm like it's
fine like it worked out you know because
if you don't appreciate effort then
they'll stop trying yeah exactly
it's a fine line
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]